Chinese President Xi Jinping calls it the
project of the century.
China's sprawling belt
and road initiative,
sometimes called the New Silk Road.
Measured in today's dollars
it has already cost more
than the US Marshal
Plan that rebuilt Europe
after World War II.
The World Bank estimates
that some $575 billion
worth of energy plants, railways, roads,
ports, and other projects have been built
or are in the works.
With 130 nations signing
deals or expressing interest
from power plants in Pakistan
to a high speed rail line
in Indonesia it's one
of the most ambitious
intercontinental infrastructure
projects in human history.
The stakes for the belt and
road project are astronomical.
Both monetarily as Morgan
Stanley estimates spending will
total $1.3 trillion by 2027.
And for China's global
image on the world stage.
China would like to make a
deal much more than I would.
As President Donald Trump scales back
US involvement in
international trade agreements
Xi is using the belt and
road to position himself
as the champion of global
cooperation, development,
and free trade.
But the project is not
without its critics.
There are accusations that
China is luring poorer countries
into debt traps for its own political
and strategic gain.
With some countries even
downsizing or completely
canceling projects even as
new deals are being signed.
Several countries have had
to rethink their involvement.
Often after popular backlash
or change of government,
or both.
For example Sri Lanka
borrowed $8 billion to build
a new port, couldn't repay the loans,
and then gave a
state-owned Chinese company
a 99 year lease in
exchange for debt relief.
The port has little business
now but provides China
a strategic berth along
key shipping lanes.
Myanmar also drastically
scaled back a port deal
struck under its previous military regime.
Originally to $7.5 billion
reduced to just $1.3 billion.
China would like to get
somewhat of a roll back.
The Trump administration has sought to
capitalize on the doubts with
Vice President Mike Pence
telling southeast Asian
nations the US would not offer
a constricting belt or a one way road.
In the face of criticism
President Xi is doing
damage control.
Calling the project a road for peace.
In 2018 the initiative
extended into South America,
the Caribbean, and even the Arctic.
In 2019 Italy became the
first group of seven nation
to sign up, brushing off
warnings from both American
and European allies.
In Asia these are the
countries that approve
of the belt and road project.
These are cautious, and these are opposed.
Overall the World Bank
says the revived silk road
has the potential to
stimulate economic growth.
But with that growth comes challenges.
Some of the risks include
allegations of corruption
like those the Kyrgyzstan
Prime Minister is facing
and potential for environmental damage.
Which prompted a Kenyan
court to order a halt to
a power plant being built on Lamu Island,
a major tourist destination.
Xi, who is dealing with
China's own debt problems
and slowing economic growth
has promised debt relief
to some African nations.
And a top Chinese regulator
called for greater
social responsibility
in overseas investments.
That's the kind of sensitivity
China will need to show
and follow through on if it's
to win over their skeptics.